hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play gary dark secrets my name is
markiplier and we are in the depths of
our in some basement somewhere uh it's
not really a big deal I forget what I'm
doing what am i doing what did I just do
ha ha ha run I'm running what are you
doing Oh wine cellar that's right that's
right that's right it's right behind me
I shouldn't turn around and look ha ha
ha ah bingo
so those two were having a little powwow
in the closet
give me why munch on some feet off I'm
in a bit of a hurry today getting behind
schedule
don't have time for your [ __ ] not
ano [ __ ] honest a fine
nevermind hmm why am i behind schedule
why am i behind schedule you might ask
Wow because I got a big session of drunk
minecraft to record today I may or may
not have had something already what's
behind here mmm ah okay I did door from
me anyway so got out of here
oh I mentioned my name is markiplier I
mentioned that I think I did if you're
trying to getting those thoughts you
won't be able to is just the key we had
an accident guess I don't know he meant
stumble on the ground where I remained
for an unknown time luckily we were able
to capture him before he could tell
anyone second longing use the key and
pull the lever you should know where it
is
I don't hopefully no we'll find both the
key lever this time okay so is there a
lever in here or where it's not here
right kliklak
what huh broken pieces uh nothing
uh health function looks like it test
files Oh [ __ ] mana potion I think in
the fire some arm with fingers never
seen fingers before lady buddy fingers
like that can't pick him up all right
anyway Peggy but Belle was looking for
101 pictures why do they need to be
behind glass one two three four five
four two four
hi something was on here and then it got
up and then it went away
why was this door locked up it oh it
went in here huh bear find out Nick
Keefer hammer [ __ ] you
yeah shut up water unless you know who
hello morphine pinning the boxes in the
boxes okay ah okay ooh that looks like
something hey get off my face dumb
behavior I can't touch those uh-huh why
are y'all looking in the corners what's
going on here
ah hello batteries oh oh
what was that one girl you can't make a
move not to do that
oh good do that Oh
oh no oh no oh
huh door unlocking I can't open it there
might be another way to do tea
Oh God a back american mood that's
totally unfair
aha I found body parts I don't think
this helps me
it's bloosh uh costal aha picked up a
key good thing I found a key not sure if
that's like as in a as in number a oh
hello come here
BAM I meant to do that more dramatically
but whatever booyah go back out oh god
damn it they're gonna do it again
I'm gonna do another one I know it
huh don't need that uh it doesn't have a
name tag why would a key have a name tag
I get that or whatever I'm outta here
ah how long were you looking at me okay
wasn't there is um door that needed a
key that door
that one yeah this one okay I got it
must be some oh yeah lever oh there's a
lever in one of them and um that room I
don't know what the note say ah door
dissection sees oh that's old one of the
doors
um maybe there's some other way to get
in I don't know
Ernie dinner already
okay maybe there's a lever in here
somewhere that I can't see I didn't see
I'm not seeing
maybe one of the arms is a lever ah
no okay
not seeing anything got my face oh don't
make anything happen again I know those
roaches were scripted now got my face
okay I don't see anything here
maybe the lover was in that back room
that make sense hopefully no one will
find the key hand the lever at the same
time so it bring it on
what you got boxes yeah here get good
done good you out of here okay looking
for a lever huh looking for lever maybe
one of the books is a lever behind there
get here piggy my hair
ah I feel ever I see
oh yeah how do i ha ha oh yeah on the
best bunk oh oh great
on the best way ham what's that where
over there said some words it was
something else
I'm just checking around make sure yeah
got my bases covered cuz I remember this
door popped up some text or else I'm
totally out of it and I'm losing my mind
which is highly possible anyway let's
see move on
no time to waste it dark ooh
odo odo odo
oh no oh
yeah dude come on come on
I'm ready for you crowbar ah yeah you
want some huh why would I jump jump
what
huh Oh
haha vacu ah thank you [ __ ] alright so
ah crowbar obviously to the other door
but let me try it on this one cuz I'm a
fool of ourselves nope nope I can't get
in that door with the manikins there was
no point going in that door besides just
triggering that event so that's dumb of
them here we go oh yeah oh yeah joy
muscles oh I amaze myself sometimes are
you leaning
okay why you mean but you know drunk
haha it happens
oh I don't
oh yeah yeah oh [ __ ] ow don't like you I
don't like you at all and stinky there's
something behind all these boxes or not
or this is what causes an exorbitant
amount of loading for these levels step
judging me
okay all right what oh there we go got
it thank you
any behind there what's that I see some
red oh it's just an evil glow from the
corner of the room that's okay that's
okay
oh well this is why I need the boxes
well I don't kill myself maybe I don't
know probably not oh okay
ah I was a very far I probably could've
made that without the boxes
I don't like this not the - where's eyes
everything I have to have a sewer level
why is everything I have to have a sewer
level and I wonder what killed that
statue for the arm the suit of armor
why would one person have so many
library this isn't the sewers oh I do
not like this
oh I definitely don't like this
something's going wrong here something
ah oh yeah oh yeah oh
nailed it I didn't see any other though
others go get into boxes yeah I didn't
see any others just that one
now whatever it's fine oh here we go
pull it pull it
okay anymore ah oh yeah oh yeah oh oh oh
oh on a roll on are all gonna make it
gonna hit gonna get it good done turn
what done framerate tank now is that to
some secret it was out well supposed to
do one oh hello there we go
not good secret but whatever I'll take
what I can get that's it anyway
that's actually all the time that I got
for this episode this episode so I'm
gonna venture down in there and after
this recording more drunk minecraft so
stick around for that it's gonna be a
big session we're gonna do a lot more of
that so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye-bye